you
I'm not gonna put them in any particular
order but I'm gonna pick five films I'm
gonna picnic rogues don't look now which
is a film my father was in I think it
changed cinema Nick Rogue has an opening
that are all flash cuts I think that
opening is about 60 seconds long and
that was his movie and then he spends
the next two hours explaining it to you
in a longer slower version I was a film
with my father and Julie Christie
unbelievably important film profound
film Lawrence of Arabia the scope of
beauty in that film the storytelling in
that film Peter O'Toole's performance
Sharif's performance kind of historical
filmmaking at its best
Godfather's one and two again
storytelling at its best unbelievably
rich performances Serpico
Al Pacino one of the great cop films of
all time and then another one I'm gonna
pick is another film of my father's in
the film called ordinary people I think
it dealt with a family dynamic and and
often crisis that is something I think
is important to communicate about I
think it's important for families that
are going through difficult times to
realize they're not alone I think that
film conveys that beautifully again the
performances Timothy Hutton Judd Hirsch
Mary Tyler Moore and my father where
exquisite that's five